[Musik]
hallo heute gibt es den carrot cake von
starbucks
ich habe mir extra gekauft es können
keine produktplatzierung es ist sogar
möglich dass die gerade meinen magen
knurren höheren habt weil man micro hier
sind man mal hier und ich habe richtig
hochwertigen welche zum mittagessen
verspeisen
so wie wir haben uns den geholt dann
kann man nachher nämlich auch schöne
geschmackstest mir dass man zur seite
und ich starte jetzt mit dem saftigen
karotten kuchen da muss richtig saftig
sein also es ist wirklich ein muss und
ich gebe jetzt hier zuallererst ja die
sind auf raumtemperatur in die
küchenmaschine so zusammen mit dem
zucker und dann schlage ich das circa
fünf minuten lang richtig schön cremig
[Musik]
sodann ganz kurz das öl einrühren und
jetzt kommen wir zu dem trockenen
zutaten übrigens alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben die findet ihr immer unten
in der video beschreibung einfach den
titel aufklappen und dann sei sie und
jetzt habe ich hier einmal mail bei
cacau dann gebe ich da noch backpulver
dazu und ich finde darf nicht fehlen so
einmal grob vorab verrühren und dann mit
zur masse 7 und auch nur ganz kurz
einrühren
[Musik]
so nachdem die trockenen zutaten nur
ganz kurz eine wird habt auch noch
vanille extrakt dazugeben und jetzt habe
ich hier erst mal den vorerst fertigen
teig dann muss es aber noch aufgepumpt
werden natürlich mit karotten die habe
ich hier fein geraspelt die gebe ich
hier direkt dazu außerdem walnüsse und
rosin ich bin ganz ehrlich ich bin kein
großer rosin fan
deswegen habe ich bei mir jetzt ein
bisschen weniger rein gegeben wenn ihr
rosi mögen dann ja du magst ja auch
nicht mehr
ja mit schokolade überzogen gehen sie
deshalb gebe ich dir noch dazu ihr könnt
die mengen wirklich variieren ihr könnt
auch mehr walnüsse und weniger rosinen
reingehen oder gar keine rosinen jetzt
habe ich das ganz kurz unter und dann
können wir das auch schon backen
[Musik]
also wenn man hier deutlich sehen kann
hat man hier viel boden anteil also vier
böden sind und die sind auch nicht
gerade dünn daher mache ich so dass ich
den boden jetzt in zwei torten regen
backe ihr könnt auch springform nehmen
vollkommen egal habe ich jetzt auf 20 cm
eingestellt und ich mache das deswegen
unterteilt auf zwei touren bringen damit
sie gleichmäßig backen wenn nicht die
masse in einem tortenring backen würde
dann wird die an der oberfläche total
austrocknen dunkel werden und in der
mitte wahrscheinlich gar nicht klar
werden dass dem boden machen wir das so
und ihr könnt den ofen auch schon mal
vorheizen 180 grad ober unterhitze das
ist ganz wichtig und dann backt er so
für ungefähr 45 minuten macht gerne die
stäbchen probe wenn man die süßen
während jetzt der boden abkühlt kümmern
wir uns um das cream cheese frosting
dafür benötigen wir zimmer warme butter
die ich jetzt zuallererst in der
küchenmaschine aufschlagen werde ich
gucke gleich auf den timer und sagt euch
dann wie viele minuten es gedauert hat
wichtig ist dass es wirklich richtig
schön hague emig ist und dann sehen wir
uns gleich wieder
[Musik]
7 bis siebeneinhalb minuten dauert das
ganze in der maschine und die butter ist
richtig schön hell cremig geworden genau
so muss es sein
und jetzt nehmen wir uns doppel ram
frischkäse wichtig ist bitte bitte nicht
die light-variante oder irgendwas
fettarmes nehmen es muss wirklich die
doppel rahmen stufe seien an frischkäse
gebe ich jetzt mit dazu nur ganz kurz
einrühren nicht zu viel sonst wird es
flüssig dann eher vanille extrakte zu
geben sehr wichtig für den geschmack und
anschließend puderzucker dass ich vorher
gesagt habe so und dann ist das frosting
eingriffen fertig sodass forsting ist
jetzt fertig und wenn es bei euch ein
bisschen weicher ist als gedacht weil
sollte schon sehr fest sein dann einfach
in die kühlung geben von der halbe
stunde oder stunde in den kühlschrank
immer wieder umrühren by me so sieht's
auch der fall weil es hier ziemlich war
bis die lichter sind an und ich mach das
gleich auch so und in der zwischenzeit
unsere saftigen böden einmal
durchschneiden und können wir bitte
heute über unsere torten see gesprächen
ich bin heute mal wieder so stolz darauf
dass wir die eben haben
es hat sich einmal mehr herausgestellt
dass es wichtig ist eben dass das
produkt gut ist ihr habt ihr kein draht
das euch einfach kaputt geht und immer
wieder ersatz braucht sondern eine echte
klinge also einen wellenschliff haben
wir hier
und das kann eben auch die nüsse
durchschneiden und ich finde das sieht
auch super super schön hast dich
beliebte hier schon die ganze zeit damit
und im nächsten schritt ganz einfach
alles füllen also super easy boden
frosting boden frosting und auch außen
einmal komplett glatt streichen und dann
sind wir fast fertig was ihr unbedingt
nicht wegwerfen dürft sind die reste von
eurem geschnittenen boten die überreste
die oben liegen bleiben die brauchen wir
nämlich gleich noch
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier noch den übrig
gebliebenen tortenboden das war der
abschluss oben den einfach gerade
weggeschnitten habt und den jetzt
einfach mit den händen richtig fein
zerbröseln und an den rand der torte
quasi dran kleben also ich habe jetzt
analyse zwei stücke und ich finde
komischerweise auch im internet kein
ganzen carrot cake also kein foto davon
aber anhand der stücke habe ich gesehen
dass dies so gemacht haben ein bisschen
machen wir das auch so so anschließend
ca 20 minuten kühne mit die oberfläche
auch schön fest und dann könnt ihr mit
weißer kuvertüre und einer kleinen loch
tolle ganz einfach das rautenmuster
aufspritzen so ist es ja im original
auch und dann seid ihr fertig und ihr
könnt euren carrot cake genießen wir
machen sind so wie wenn jetzt erst mal
diese entziehen schoten also der haben
seite macht es dann gleich und die fotos
et cetera und dann probieren wir
natürlich original und mainz und ist
solch ein bisschen schief es ist so es
ist unser akku ist leer gegangen aber
machen professionell weiter ist nicht
schlimm
was ich sagen wollte wir probieren das
gleichauf instagram weil wie gesagt muss
noch geschultert werden und wenn wir uns
auf instagram noch nicht folgt dann holt
das doch jetzt schnell nach tier gesehen
schon gesehen ansonsten werden die sie
euch am ende des videos einfügen und
dann den ehrlichen geschmackstest machen
wir werden auch wirklich ehrlich sein
problemfall okay ganz viel freude euch
beim nachbarn ich verabschiede mich
schonmal offizier haben das handtuch b
also bis zum nächsten jahren bleibt bis
zum schluss dran
ich kann es verstehen die leute das
nachmachen wollen
das schlägt sich gut in die tour ist
also weiter aber ich bin dein
schmeckt echt fläche man merkt die
richtung dass natürliche zutaten bei
hier ist es einfach nur bemerkt das ist
einmal von draußen gekauft es egal ob
das jetzt fertig gekauft ist bei core i3
oder kanada ist erwachsener merkt es ist
industriell gemacht wurde ich möchte es
einfach so fort wobei die ist einfach
diese liebe die man schmeckt was
möchtest du schatz kaffee tee sagt
irgendwas machen
ja es gibt punkte gutgemacht
[Musik]